[MUSIC PLAYING]
JEFF ALLEN: So hello.
I'm Jeff Allen.
I'm a Cloud Solutions
Architect from Google Cloud.
And I'm here also with Rick
Dehlinger and Rich Meesters
from Citrix.
And they're going to
be joining us as we
get into this presentation.
This is CMP206, Journey
to the Cloud Confidently
with Citrix and Google Cloud.
What we're going to
talk about today,
one is a demo of our
open source project
that helps you build
Citrix environments on GCP.
We're also going to talk about
the Citrix Workspace vision.
Talk about the architectural
components of Citrix on GCP.
And walk through a
number of architectures,
including a reference
architecture, as well as
some examples that we've
worked with customers.
So let's dig right into this.
We're starting
with a demo, which
I think it breaks some
rules in breakout sessions
that you start with a demo.
But the reason that
we're doing this
is we want to show really
how quickly and easily you
can set up Citrix on GCP,
leveraging the open source
project we have on GitHub.
And so if we start the
scripts at the beginning,
we'll be able to come back by
the end of the presentation
to actually explore this
environment that we've
built in the course
of a breakout session.
So we're going to
start by looking
at this GitHub project we have.
It's based on the
deployment guide
that Citrix authored in 2017.
Released a sort of
reference architecture
for how to build Citrix
environments on GCP.
And we wanted to make it easy
to walk through an automated
process to build
those environments.
So we used Deployment
Manager PowerShell scripts
to bootstrap the instances
so you can basically
take that environment that's
described in that document
and build it by just kicking
off a script from GitHub.
All you have to do is clone
the GitHub repository,
citrix-on-gcp.
Run a script, deploy.ps1,
that kicks off
the Deployment Manager.
And then come back to it.
Currently the latest
version of this
takes about 22 minutes
to deploy an environment
and you've got a working
environment to explore.
It sets up Notepad as
a sample virtual app,
but we have a branch that
shows you in the project
how to customize
that if you want
to set up additional apps in
your Citrix on GCP environment.
And then once it's built,
you use the Citrix workspace
to access those virtual apps.
And we also have
a script in there
to resize the fleet that
does some rudimentary fleet
management.
Initially it builds the virtual
fleet with just one instance,
but you can run
this resize script
if you want to add
additional capacity.
So maybe you're doing a demo.
It gets popular.
You need some additional
capacity for virtual sessions.
You can run that
resize script to have
a larger fleet of workers.
And there's a cleanup
script that you
can run at the end, which tears
down all of the GCP resources
and it also cleans up the
Citrix Cloud resources.
Because this
bootstrap's not only
the Google environment, but
also the Citrix environment.
And this cleanup
script will tear down
both of the environments,
so it doesn't leave you
with any stranded objects.
Doesn't leave you
with any billing
once you're done with the demo.
Now if you'll switch to
the laptop, what we're
going to look at
today is actually not
in the master branch of
our GitHub repository.
It's in a branch
called experimental,
which you're welcome
to check out.
We've been working on improving
the speed of the build
and also reworking
the architecture a bit
to take advantage of some of
the newer managed resources.
Like when the initial
architecture came out,
GCP didn't have a
managed cloud NAT.
We do now.
NAT is a service.
And so we've been
reworking the architecture
to take advantage of
those newer services.
So this experimental
branch is sort
of the leading edge of where
this project is and it deploys
faster and actually more
simply leveraging those managed
services.
So let's take a look.
This is the Google Cloud
Platform console, obviously.
We're going to hop
into Cloud Shell.
And hopefully we can
hop into Cloud Shell.
OK, so I have this
checked out already.
So we can go to GitHub, Google
Cloud Platform, Citrix on GCP.
And I'll do a git status.
We'll just see
that I'm up to date
with the experimental branch.
Now there's still a
deploy.ps1 script.
I'm hopping into
PowerShell, by the way.
If you're interested in running
PowerShell in Cloud Shell,
hit me up and I'll show
you how to set that up.
But all you have to do to
set this up is run deploy.ps1
and then give it
some parameters.
This sets up Active Directory as
part of the environment that it
bootstraps.
Active Directory, along with
all the Citrix configurations.
So it's going to set up an
Active Directory domain.
We're going to say
domain example.org.
Give it a [INAUDIBLE] name.
I'm going to give it a flag
called use minimal resources.
One of the nice things
about this project
is that you can
use trial accounts,
both for Google and for Citrix.
So you can run this
actually for free.
And use minimal resources
as a small footprint
version that works within
the free tier limitations.
I'm going to tell it a region.
Let's use us-west1.
And this is new in the
experimental branch.
I'm going to tell it Citrix
creds for credentials path.
This is a JSON file.
It's described in the Read Me.
But it's a JSON file that
has the Citrix Client API
credentials so that it can
connect with the Citrix API
and bootstrap the Citrix
Cloud environment.
And so I've created a JSON
file and have these loaded
in Google Cloud Storage.
And so basically
this is all that you
need to do to build a
Citrix environment on GCP.
We'll kick this off.
And something's wrong.
Oh.
It's Citrix creds URL.
There we go.
And so we'll see that it's
going to initialize a few things
and then very quickly go into
Deployment Manager, where
Deployment Manager
is going to recognize
that there's a deployment
that's been kicked off.
It's an asynchronous operation.
It's going to stand
up some instances,
bootstrap those instances.
Put a pin in this.
We'll come back to it towards
the end of our presentation.
Take a look at
what it just built
and actually access
that environment,
run the virtual app,
and see how it works.
So if we'll go
back to the slides,
I'm going to turn the floor
over to Rick Dehlinger, who's
going to share with us about
the Citrix Workspace vision.
RICK DEHLINGER: Why
thank you, Jeff.
So what'd you think of
the interesting start?
Kicking off a demo right at
the beginning of a session.
A little interesting, a little
bit of a twist, and perhaps
a little cart before the horse.
So I'd actually like to
start my section here
with a couple of
questions for you.
So for starters, how many
of you have heard of or used
Citrix technologies before?
I see a pretty fair
amount of hands.
All right, then how many of
you have been Citrix customers
and used this stuff in
production over the years?
All right, I'm going to call
that probably 30% maybe.
Somewhere along those lines.
All right.
So I'd wanted to ask that
question to kind of set
the stage a little bit.
Because, as I mentioned,
we in some regards
put the cart before
the horse a little bit.
So if some of you have not
heard of Citrix before,
you may not have
the faintest clue
what it was that we were
actually showing you there.
So I'm going to
take some time here
in this section to go
ahead and illustrate
a few things for you.
So for starters, if we take a
look at Citrix as a company,
we're actually not unlike a
lot of you, I would imagine.
In that we've been an
enterprise organization that's
been around for a long time.
Has a lot of history and a lot
of infrastructure of our own.
History of products and
acquisitions that we've
been dealing with over time.
But we were founded around
this idea of taking originally
the OS 2 operating
system, turning it
into a multi-user operating
system, which it wasn't
at the time, and allowing people
to connect into that remotely.
So that whole concept of
taking platforms and making
them mainframe-like,
if you will,
giving you the ability to
connect to them remotely,
is kind of where the
organization started.
And that goes back into
1991 was about the time
that the first
product was launched.
And over time, Citrix has
evolved substantially.
So we're all about remote access
for many, many, many years.
And somewhere around
the 2006 frame,
actually backing it up so.
Remote access primarily
to Windows applications.
That's really where the bulk of
the growth in our organization
or our business came from.
So it was around
2006 that we actually
introduced some best
of breed networking
technologies and our application
delivery controllers.
And then moving
forward, you'll see
a bit more of the transition
that we've made across time.
And I'm not going to
touch on all of these
in the instance of time.
But kind of the place that
we've landed ultimately,
and we're still at today.
We've got this capability
or this vision of the Citrix
Secure Workspace that I'm
going to chat with you
a little bit about today.
So one common theme
here is that, with all
the different spaces that we've
been as we've been evolving
dramatically alongside
the IT industry over time,
one thing that's been kind of
a common thread of what we've
been doing is that
we've always been trying
to lead the future of work.
So let me describe
that a little bit more.
So at Citrix, we
fundamentally believe
that work is something that you
do, not some place that you go.
And today's
technologies actually
make that a lot more
feasible than they did.
And roll back even
five years, 10 years,
dare I even go back 15 years.
And in our current
vision and the way
that we're building and
bringing the product to market,
we put people and
security at the center
of everything it is that we do.
So if you think about any
given knowledge worker,
the next generation,
the cloud workers
that are coming into
the workforce today,
or the way that a lot
of our knowledge workers
are transitioning into more like
Cloud workers, where they're
innovating versus just going
along with business as usual,
one common scenario
that you see is
that the users tend to be
roaming around, accessing,
or needing to access their
corporate applications
and data from a variety
of different devices
and a variety of
different locations.
Now those resources.
they may be accessing
could be stored anywhere today.
They could be in the cloud.
They could be in an on
premises or customer managed
type of a data center.
Or they could be
applications or services
that you're consuming
from the public cloud.
But the key here is that we put
the user in the middle of that.
Now kind of stepping forward
into the Citrix of today.
So we're not the
smallest organization.
We've been around for
quite a few years.
Since the 1989 time frame.
So what we're all about
today is this whole concept
of the intelligent workspace.
And the intelligent
workspace is really
there are a lot of parallels
if you know and understand
the Google Cloud worker vision,
and the direction that Google
is taking it with a combination
of things like Chrome,
and Chrome enterprise, and the
G Suite applications, and IAP.
And a lot of the
different services
that are available on GCP.
Our intelligent workspace
vision and the products
that we're developing and
bringing to market today
to help make that happen are
all about bringing together
the apps, and information, and
services that the users need
to do their job and to innovate,
bringing those to any device
that they may have
available to them
at any point in time
over any type of network
that they've got.
And so this vision of the
intelligent workspace,
we make the assumption
that the user
is going to need to be able to
access those resources wherever
they happen to be.
So we take the
perimeter that used
to be the corporate firewall
at your primary data
center for an organization.
And we're essentially
moving that perimeter.
Instead of being at the edge
of a business or a data center,
we're moving that perimeter out
around the actual user itself.
So the Citrix of today, we
count over 400,000 customers.
And those are customers
as in businesses.
We don't really have any
consumer-facing technologies
in the market today.
We've got coverage through a
large percentage of the Fortune
500.
And ultimately, we've got over
100 million licensed users
out in the market space.
So we've grown a heck of a lot.
And along the way,
as I've mentioned,
we historically probably
very similar to you
had been building services
and building products
that we've been shipping
kind of traditionally, right?
So fall in the old
traditional waterfall model.
Building package products
that we would then
test, and put in a box, and
actually ship people a box.
So over time we've been
on pretty substantial
digital transformation
of our own.
Moving our own business
away from that model
of delivering perpetual
products and moving
into the delivery of those
technologies via services.
So you'll hear us talk
about this thing called
Citrix Cloud today.
And I want to ensure you
that this is not an IS.
You're not going to
go buy some compute,
and some networking, and
some storage from us.
So Citrix Cloud is
our platform that we
leverage to deliver all
these innovative services
to our customers.
So this platform is cloud-based.
We're doing all the
similar types of things
with rapid iteration, and
release cycles, and canarying
of releases, and all of
those kinds of things
that you're probably
also dealing with.
But with this
cloud-based platform,
we're pre-integrating
the services.
So you can consume multiple
different services on their own
to solve point problems.
Or you can consume
multiple services together
and the platform itself
integrates those services
and saves you from
a lot of the work.
Then we're also
with the platform,
managing, and maintaining,
and upgrading,
and keeping evergreen
all the components that
go into this solution.
But one point I'll make
here is that Citrix
has a lot of experience from
our digital transformation.
One kind of unique thing
that we've been doing
is taking those experiences
and our lessons learned
and rolling those into features
and capabilities of our cloud
platform.
So one of the things that
we pride ourselves on
is providing apps and
services via Citrix Cloud that
help our enterprise
customers with their digital
transformation journeys.
Meet them on their journey,
and help add some value,
and help them get
more of the value out
of digital transformation.
So I'm not going to touch
on all these points here,
but I just want to point
out a couple of key things.
For starters, you'd
recognize that date of 2011.
That was the launch of
Chrome, and the Chrome OS,
and Chromebooks.
So Citrix was actually one
of the launch partners,
one of the key partners.
So we brought at the
time it was our Citrix
Receiver we brought to market.
And that allowed organizations
to adopt Chromebooks
for their end user access.
And it gave the
business and IT a way
to deliver their call them
legacy today applications,
like Windows applications
and Linux-based applications,
deliver those down
to Chromebooks.
So we've seen a lot of success.
And if you look over the
years, the main thing
I want you to pick out from this
is the velocity of innovation.
So especially as you get
into the last three years,
you'll see that the
velocity of innovation
and the co-investment on
both sides of this alliance
has been substantial.
And you're going to continue to
see a lot more of that evolve
as time goes.
So very quickly, the
ecosystem of solutions that we
provide here.
Kind of the center, if you
will, of the user experience
is this thing called the
Citrix Workspace platform.
It's accessed through this thing
called the Citrix Workspace
app, which is
either a web browser
or it's a native app across all
different types of platforms.
And it's kind of that
common consumption point
or aggregation point
of those virtualized
Windows apps as being one
of the types of services.
But we're also delivering things
like SAS-based applications.
Doing single sign
on to those things,
wrapping a bunch of advanced
analytics and security services
around those.
And here very recently,
well, very recently
being the last year
and a half or so,
we've also substantially
stepped up the capabilities
to deploy virtualized
apps and desktops on GCP.
So pulling this back around to
that demo that we started with.
So that demo that we
started with was showing you
an automated very
simple way to get
started deploying virtualized
applications and desktops
on GCP.
The key point I
want to make there
is that Citrix is not just about
virtualized apps and desktops.
We still do that a lot.
However, we've got a lot more
services and capabilities
available in the
marketplace today.
So the solution
areas that you'll
find us working together
on, you can see kind
of a quick snapshot of here.
So on the productivity
and Workspace area,
if you're using G Suite
in the Workspace app,
we provide our content
collaboration capabilities
that snap into G Suite
in the workspace.
We provide this advanced access
control that if you want to you
can come check out in
booth and we'll show you
off some of that stuff.
On the far right, we're talking
about our Endpoint Management
capabilities, which are
built into Citrix Cloud.
And those integrate
and work very well
with both Chrome Enterprise
and with Android Enterprise,
Android for Work.
And then finally, if
you're in the GCP world,
if that's kind of where
your technology focus is,
and where we're going to
spend the bulk of the rest
of our time here in
this session, then
you're leveraging GCP to deploy
our virtual apps and desktops.
Also some of our networking
technologies and appliances.
And that's the area
that we're going
to be focusing on for the
rest of the afternoon session.
So at this point, I'm
going to turn things over
to my colleague
here, Rich Meesters,
to take us through a
little bit more depth.
Take us away.
RICH MEESTERS: Thanks, Rick.
Watch where the
mic goes, I guess.
So what I want to do is
delve a little bit further
down into the architectural
components of Citrix Virtual
Apps and Desktops on GCP.
Rick has gone through
what Citrix Cloud was,
what the Workspace is.
Really it's a bunch of
cloud-delivered services
that wrap around this
whole Workspace experience.
A lot of these will come into
play in that Citrix Google
ecosystem in terms of
delivering an overall service
to your customers.
But what we want to focus
on is really those items
that we're dealing
with in the demo.
And fundamentally there
what we're looking at
is what Jeff started building
at the beginning of this session
and the focus of the
components that we're
putting on Google Cloud
is really the Virtual Apps
and Desktop services.
And then we're going
to front end that
with the Workspace and
the Workspace experience
from an end user experience
perspective coming off
the Chromebook.
So what is the Citrix Virtual
Apps and Desktop Services?
I think Rick kind of covered it.
It's really the
foundation of what
we've been doing at Citrix
for the last approximately
30 years.
And that is deploying
Windows workloads
and now Linux workloads
in a centralized location,
whether that's on
a customer premise
or in a public cloud like
GCP, and then allowing users
to access those applications
in a secure fashion.
So the Citrix Virtual
Apps and Desktop service
itself is really the
cloud-hosted control plane.
And that's
Citrix-managed component.
So that's the glue that holds
all of the infrastructure
together.
As well as workloads that our
customers put in their data
centers wherever they
may want to put them.
So in their data centers in
public cloud, pretty much
wherever they want to put them.
And then the user's
access those applications
using the Workspace
App anywhere, anytime,
from any device that they
want to access them from.
The key components
here that will
start to kind of break
down and talk about,
the Citrix Connectors.
They're the component
that provide
that link between
customers' GCP, resource
location, and the Citrix
Cloud control plane.
As well as the VDAs,
which is the agent,
or what we call a Virtual
Delivery Agent, that we install
on the virtual desktops
or the Windows Server,
The Linux Server,
to provide access
to the applications on it.
So in terms of what components
we actually require,
our minimal set is we need
a couple of Citrix Cloud
Connectors.
And those are Windows
Server instances.
And the Virtual Delivery Agents.
So those agents running
on Windows or Linux
instances to deliver
the applications.
Other components
that we require.
Active Directory is required
for a Citrix system.
All of our Windows
machines are domain joined.
And so you absolutely have
to have Active Directory
in your environment.
But in many customer situations,
from a security perspective,
they don't at least
initially want
to put Active Directory
controllers into a public cloud
infrastructure.
So really what we need
is we need the service.
Other optional components that
we have within the environment.
We have SMB file shares
for Windows user profiles.
We have our Citrix
ADCs or gateways.
And we'll talk a little bit
more about what the ADC does,
but it's part of our access
to your infrastructure.
As well as StoreFront.
We've talked about the Workspace
and Workspace experience.
Some customers opt to go with
our older version of that,
which is StoreFront,
and then they
can build that within
their own infrastructure
and control the routing
of their traffic
through those infrastructures.
And finally, Federated
Authentication
and Certificate
Services are components
that allow us to federate
SAML based authentication
into our Active
Directory components.
So these are other
additional components
that we'll talk a
little bit about as we
go through the
reference architectures.
So the Cloud
Connectors, as we said,
they really provide
that glue or that layer
in between the customer's
environment and the Citrix
Managed Control plane.
And they're there
to provide services
to support the connection
between those two components.
We do say we want to have two
Connectors in every resource
location that we have.
These Connectors are
Citrix-managed components.
So we will reach down
to those components.
Or when they reach up to us,
we'll check their version
and we will update
them periodically.
So we want to have
a minimum of two
of those in any
resource location
so we maintain
high availability.
We also want to put
these Connectors
in different availability
zones within GCP
so that we can
tolerate, again, we
get higher levels
of availability
and tolerate potential
failures within a zone.
Within that component,
there's multiple services
that are running.
The Secure Ticket Authority
is used by the gateway
to ensure that
communications are
secure between the front end,
user end, and the back end.
Gateway services, if we're
using the Gateway in the cloud,
provides that path for the
traffic from the workload
to the user's end
point to transit.
Brokering, kind of
its primary function
is just to make sure that
users are getting access
to the resources they need, as
well as provisioning services,
and we'll talk a little bit
about machine creation services
later, which allow us to do
single instance management
and managing the identity.
So Citrix does not maintain
the customer's Active Directory
in our control plane.
The customer maintains that on
their own resource location.
And the identity service within
the Connector will manage that.
Typically what we see
with these are usually
4 vCPUs and 12 to
16 gigabytes of RAM.
And the communication
from the Connector
is a TLS 1.2 outbound
only connection
to the Citrix control plane.
The Windows Virtual
Delivery Agent.
This is the component that
sits on top of the workloads.
And it connects the
Windows and Linux instances
to the Virtual Apps
and Desktop service.
It's a software package that's
installed on that server
or desktop instance.
And it basically communicates
with the Connectors
on GCP port 80 to register
itself with the system
and also communicates out
to the end users outbound
with TCP 1494/2598 natively.
And often that is done through
a gateway service, where that
is then encapsulated in 443.
Now one of the
important points when
you're looking at
your infrastructure
is the scalability.
Most of your
infrastructure that you
build in a Citrix environment
is going to be workload.
We have a few Connector servers.
We'll have some store
front, potentially.
Some federated
authentication services.
But you're really only
talking about a handful
of servers at that point.
So your majority is going to
be either virtual desktops
or Windows servers that
are publishing apps.
And because of that,
scalability of these
plays a major part in
looking at your design.
For VDI, it's really simple.
It's kind of picking out the
best instance type that you
might have for your workload.
For server based
computing then, we
start to want to look at single
instance scalability within GCP
to understand how many users
can we get on a given workload.
And Citrix did last year some
baseline scalability testing.
We used Login VSI and we worked
through several iterations
of various instance
types in GCP.
And what we found at that time
was the best instance type
that we had or instance size
that we had was the N1 standard
8 for the workloads,
[INAUDIBLE] app workloads,
for server-based
computing workloads.
And we ran about 33
users per VM on that
using a standardized knowledge
workload in Login VSI.
Other considerations here.
You want to look at optimizing
your costs through discounts.
So of course, if you're
familiar with GCP,
you know that by
default something
that GCP has that other cloud
providers don't have are
the sustained use discounts.
So taking a look at how you
discount your environment
based on VMs running
over a period of time.
And there's a good
amount of detail here
that I'm not going to go into.
But also the committed use
discount, which is more,
I guess, a traditional
discounting
you'll see across
cloud providers, where
you have one and three
year commitments where
you pay a certain amount and
then you run those workloads
100% of the time.
Certainly for some of
the control element
workloads that you may put
in your resource location,
this is a really good
idea to take a look at.
Because you know they're going
to be running 100% of the time.
But we also want to take a look
at it from a perspective of,
what does it mean for
running workloads?
And Jeff was good enough
to put this graph together
for us, as we did some of
our architecture discussions,
to kind of take a look
at the breakpoints
here for sustained and
committed use discounts.
So the green is the
standard sustained use
and how it increases over time.
The blue curve is a
three year committed use
and the purple curve is
a one year committed use.
So what you see here where
those lines intersect is really
the point at which it
starts to make sense
to consider those committed use
discounts for your workloads.
For instance here, if
you're running your workload
for 50% of the
time over a month,
then you want to start
to consider looking
at committed use discounts.
The other thing to consider
for those workloads that
aren't going to be
using committed use
is our autoscale technology.
And this is a
technology that Citrix
has developed within
the product that
allows us to take our
workloads and dynamically power
manage them based on
schedule and load.
So we can define within
our configurations
within Citrix when machines
should be started up
based on a schedule.
So Monday to Friday
8:00 to 5:00 you
should have x number
of machines running.
Overnight you should
have x minus 5,
on weekends you should
have x minus 10.
And we can also then bundle
that in with load-based
for our server-based computing
and say when our load exceeds
a certain point, then I'm
going to start to scale up
additional machines.
Finally, the Citrix ADC on GCP.
So this is our Application
Delivery Controller.
And that is what we
used to call NetScaler.
Names have changed recently.
The functionality that we have
in that that we're primarily
looking at when we're
doing Citrix on GCP
are using it as an ICA
proxy gateway as opposed
to using the gateway services.
And that's when
customers want to bring
their own routing into play.
So they don't want to
route through the internet.
They want to route in and out
of their GCP resource locations
individually to control traffic.
As well as load
balancing for components.
If we put StoreFront
in place, for instance.
And potentially content
switching, as well.
We do support single and multi
NIC configurations in that.
So we can define our topology
from a network perspective
and understand how our
communications are going
to happen within our VNets.
And we can deploy it today
as standalone instances.
They're not yet
available in the store.
So we have them as a download
and then there's a step
by step deployment,
the URL here,
as well as some
Deployment Manager scripts
to get those going.
On the horizon what
we're looking at really
these are things
that we're looking
at coming out with this
year and into next year.
Machine Creation Services.
Right now we can power
manage machines within GCP.
But what we want to
do is get into being
able to have a single instance
management across a number
of machines, so we can manage
a single OS application package
and then deploy it
to multiple machines.
Having native Google ID
support in Citrix Workspace.
So rather than having to
log on with Active Directory
credentials, being able to log
on directly with your Google
ID.
As well as SD-WAN on GCP.
And there was an announcement
today about that.
SD-WAN on GCP will be available
within the store coming up
in one month.
And SD-WAN is used for
software-defined networking
and setting up paths
between branches and data
centers having multiple
redundant paths and logic
and how you switch between them.
And as well on the ADC side,
we have some enhancements
coming up, primarily around HA.
Having multiple ADCs and
being able to manage them.
As well as, again, integrating
those into the marketplace.
So with that, let me
turn it back over to Jeff
and we'll do a walk through
of the reference architecture.
JEFF ALLEN: Thanks, Rich.
So what we're going to
do, take these pieces
of the architecture
that Rich just
told us about, the Cloud
Connectors, the VDA, et cetera.
And we're going to explore.
Basically this is kind of a
simple reference architecture,
similar to actually what's
being built by the scripts.
And we're going to look
at a couple of workflows
to explore what each
architectural component is
doing in those workflows.
So the first one
we're going to look at
is what happens when a user
logs in to the Citrix Workspace.
So it starts on
the user's device,
whether it's a laptop,
tablet, phone, whatever.
For whatever operating
system, there
are native Citrix
Workspace apps.
There's also an
HTML5 Workspace app
that you can access
in the browser.
And so the user will access the
Citrix Workspace and log in.
Now that log in request
goes up to Citrix Cloud.
Citrix Cloud doesn't
authenticate the user directly.
Citrix Cloud actually
delegates that authentication
to the Active Directory
that's installed
in the GCP environment.
And so it does that by
communicating with those Cloud
Connectors.
It passes along that
authentication request
through the Cloud
Connectors, which actually
then authenticate the user
against the Active Directory
domain controllers.
Those Active Directory
domain controllers
may be standalone
domain controllers,
like they are in
the demo environment
that our scripts are building.
But more often than
not, it's some kind
of maybe a replication scenario
where an on-prem Active
Directory is being
replicated into the cloud
or there's some kind of trust
relationship set up there.
But once those
domain controllers
authenticate the user,
they'll pass back
through Cloud Connector,
the authentication results.
Citrix Cloud will then say,
OK, I know who this user is.
Now Citrix Cloud makes an
authorization decision.
What does that user
have access to?
That's part of the control
plane functionality
that exists in Citrus Cloud.
So it'll decide what virtual
apps, what virtual desktops
does that user have access to.
And then it will
render in the Workspace
a menu that allows
the user to choose
from one of the apps or desktops
that they have access to.
So then the next workflow
we want to look at
is what happens then when a
user chooses a virtual app
and how does that
app get launched
and how does that work.
So again, we're starting here.
The user is going to
say, click on Notepad.
I want to run Notepad
as a virtual app.
So that requests will go
up through Citrix Cloud.
And Citrix Cloud is going
to then make a decision.
There's a load
balancing decision here.
Because you know,
this is a fleet
of servers being used
by a group of users.
And we have to
allocate a session
on one of those servers.
These are the VDAs.
We have to make an
allocation decision.
This is a session brokering
and management capabilities
of Citrix Cloud.
So we'll say, OK.
Well this Notepad
session, I'm going
to allocate that on one of
my available VDA servers.
Now it's going to pass
that session initialization
information into the VDA, again,
through the Cloud Connectors.
And then Cloud Connector will
pass that along to the VDA.
The VDA will actually
then log in as the user,
launch Notepad, and then
initialize that user's
virtual app session.
This is the ICA traffic, which
we talked about, ICA proxies.
Now by default,
the ICA traffic is
going to stream
from the VDA server
directly to Citrix Cloud
if there's connectivity
between the VDA
and Citrix Cloud.
It's going to go through the
gateway service of Citrix Cloud
and then back to
the end user device.
Now if the VDA can't communicate
directly with Citrix Cloud,
it'll proxy that traffic
through the Cloud Connectors.
So there's some path
decisions being made here.
But assuming that that VDA can
communicate with Citrix Cloud,
it's going to stream that ICA
traffic through the gateway
service of Citrix Cloud
and then back to that end
user who then is
going to see Notepad
running on their device.
And that's basically what we'll
demo at the end of the session.
Now that was a quick
walk through of sort
of a reference architecture.
And now Rick is
going to join me.
And we're going to actually walk
through a couple of real world
architectures.
Maybe how we adapted them.
How they're a little
bit similar to,
but in some ways different
than the reference architecture
we just looked at.
RICK DEHLINGER: Yeah.
So one thing that you'll find
about Citrix technologies
and about Citrix Cloud is that
they're cloud services, right?
So there's a lot of flexibility
in what you can consume,
how you want to consume it.
We can leverage technologies
to tie the services together
from an automation standpoint.
Build those services.
So you actually have a lot of
flexibility in what you can do
and what you can
actually build with it.
So I'll give it a
little bit of a pitch
to come down and check out the
booth later on because we've
got a couple of interesting
use cases we've built there.
So we wanted to share
with you to start off
with this first customer.
I'm not going to dive too deeply
into it because we've actually
got a public case study that
will be out there very, very
shortly on this.
This case study is very
representative of a lot
of traditional Citrix customers.
So they've been a Citrix
customer for some time.
And they're facing a lot of the
similar type of IT challenges
that you may be facing
as you're making
your transition to the
cloud at your organization.
So they've had Citrix in
place for a long time.
They've been forced to deal with
and come up with ways that they
can consume cloud-based
services to make
them more efficient,
more agile as an IT team.
And they're also
under some pressure
to reduce the costs of running
their own data centers.
So they've made some decisions
to move some of their workloads
up into the cloud.
In the process, they
decided to start to consume
our cloud-delivered services.
And ultimately what they've
ended up getting out of this
is a system that's much
more functional than what
they've got.
They're able now to deliver
SAS-based apps and mobile apps
and such alongside their
Windows-based apps.
They've got consumption-based
pricing of the infrastructure.
And they're offloading a lot
of the management efforts
both onto Citrix
and onto Google,
which allows them to deliver
better services more quickly.
So I'll leave it on that.
And then I want to
touch on one here
that I don't have a customer
name to share for you here.
But this use case is a little
bit different in that one,
it's education.
But I think you'll see some
relative parallels here.
So in this case, we'd
had a school system
that had been teaching
their students
heavyweight applications
like the AutoCAD suite.
And the way they'd
been doing that
traditionally is by investing
in these big monstrous
workstations.
And they put these workstations
onto these mobile carts
that they would roll
around room to room.
And then as they would
have x number of students,
they'd roll the
carts into a room,
fire those things up,
and do their thing.
Well, half the time those
things ended up just
sitting there doing nothing
when they're not in class
and they paid for
them all up front.
Then of course, over
time, those things
become antiquated and
need to be replaced,
which was the driving force
behind this engagement with us.
So what they ultimately
ended up doing
was leveraging GCP, our Citrix
Virtual Apps and Desktops,
and also leveraging
Nvidia's GPO instances
that you can run out on GCP.
So they're now running these
apps out of a GCP location
near.
They're paying for their
consumption of both GPU
and compute based on usage.
So it ends up being
substantially less expensive
for them.
And they're now able to
logistically just have
the students use
whatever device they
happen to bring in
and run those things.
So real quickly, so I leave
some room for Jeff here,
the architecture that was
deployed for these guys
actually is very
similar to the one
that you see popping out the
back end of this automation
tooling.
So it was all very similar.
The one difference from
the reference architecture
that Jeff shared
with you earlier
is that the instances,
instead of just
being the general
purpose instances,
they're actually
instances with Nvidia
GPUs and their virtual vDWS.
I always stumble on what
that acronym stands for.
But they're basically
GPU accelerated instances
that run up inside of GCP.
They're also leveraging
Citrix Gateways
at the perimeter of GCP.
And the reason they did
that is because they
wanted to have the absolute
best possible performance.
So they got their users closest
to the nearest GCP region.
They've got their
gateways there as well.
So they've got the
utmost of performance
of the pipe, the lowest
possible latency.
And they've also got the
fullest featured protocol
stack in the midst of it.
So with that, I'm going to
go ahead and hand it over
to this last one.
RICH MEESTERS: So this
customer, this next customer,
was a public sector
organization with a mission
critical multi-tier app.
Some of the challenges.
They had heavy
database interactions.
They are trying to
move to the cloud,
but they're having
trouble because if they
move the application
away from the database,
they weren't getting
great performance.
They have a
distributed workforce.
So around the country, they only
get to access this application.
And they weren't getting
consistent performance.
And they'd also invested
in an on-prem multi-factor
authentication scheme
using smart cards.
And even in the
cloud, they needed
to authenticate their users
against this smart card
infrastructure.
So the solution was to move the
application and the database
into Google Cloud so that
the chatty application was
close to the database
in Google Cloud,
leveraging the Google global
network for distributing
this application using
Citrix and virtual apps
to their distributed workforce.
And the unique thing
about our configuration
was that we set up
federated authentication
against that on-prem
identity provider.
So they could leverage their
existing infrastructure
to authenticate users.
So again, it's similar to
the architecture we already
looked at.
A couple of differences.
One, you'll notice that the
client devices don't initially
talk to the Citrix Cloud
when they authenticate users.
Now they're configured.
The gateway is actually
running on an appliance in GCP.
And this gives you a
lot more flexibility
to how you configure
that appliance.
Here it's configured
not to authenticate
against the local Active
Directory domain controller,
but instead using
SAML to use that
on prem identity provider,
which allowed this customer
to leverage the smart cards
to do their authentication.
And then once the users
are authenticated,
then the workflow is similar
to what we looked at earlier.
All right.
So we've got a few minutes left.
Let's hop back to our
laptop and take a look
at our demo environment.
See if it builds happily
and if we have something
that we can take a look at.
So they deployed four instance.
The Cloud Connector.
The CC is the Cloud Connector
we've been talking about.
The DC is a Domain Controller,
an Active Directory Domain
Controller.
The third one, which
is shut down now,
we called it management.
It really was just
a script runner.
It ran the scripts that actually
configured Citrix Cloud.
So once it was done, there
was nothing else to do,
so it shuts itself down.
The way we've set
up this deployment.
And then the XA, that's
the VDA server right there.
And so this is that
simple architecture
we looked at, where we've got
a Cloud Connector, the Domain
Controller, and a
small VDA fleet.
Now if you want to log into
this environment that's
been set up for you, one
thing that you have to do
is acquire some
user credentials.
We have pre-populated
the Active Directory
domain with some sample users.
And so there is a PowerShell
script in that same directory
that we were in before
called get domain users.
And what it will do
is it will reach out
to Google Cloud Storage.
Now first it's going to ask
us which deployment do we want
to retrieve these users for.
Because you can actually
have multiple of these sample
deployments running
in your project.
The one we just ran
is number five here.
It's going to reach out
to Google Cloud Storage
and retrieve an
encrypted blob where
we have stored the usernames and
passwords of some sample users.
And then it's going to decrypt
that blob using our KMS
service.
So we've stored that
not in plain text,
but as an encrypted blob.
And here we can see the
usernames and passwords.
So let's just say we're
going to log in as user 5.
I'm copying that
password for user 5.
And we can bring up
the Citrix Workspace.
And fingers crossed, we should
be able to say we want to log
in as user_5@example.org
and paste that password in.
And that Citrix Workspace.
Now remember, this is
going to Citrix Cloud,
through the Cloud Connector,
against our Active Directory
Domain Controller.
We have successfully
logged in now.
If we go look at
View All Apps, we
should see Notepad was set up.
We are authorized to use
the Virtual App Notepad.
And if we click on
that, that, again,
should send that request
to initialize the session
through Citrix Cloud, through
the session brokering,
through Cloud Connector to
launch the session on the VDA.
Here we see it's logging in.
And momentarily what we
should see on a Chromebook now
is a window that pops up to
let us access our Windows
app, which is Notepad.
And this environment, was
built, again, hands off.
Took about 22 minutes or so
if you run those scripts.
So if you'll switch
back to the slides.
All that's out on
GitHub for you.
And we invite you
to check it out.
GoogleCloudPlatform/citrix
on gcp.
And we love pull requests.
So if you like hacking on code.
If you come up with some way to
improve the deployment scripts
and you want to
contribute back, please
reach out to us through
the GitHub project.
JEFF ALLEN: All right.
So let's take it home and
wrap this up, shall we?
So one thing I hope you
gathered from this session today
is that you at least
got a taste of the fact
that Citrix is about a lot
more than just virtualized apps
and desktops.
So I'd encourage you to come
take a look at the Citrix
booth.
We're down the expo floor.
We're showing some kind of
unique and innovative use cases
there, but we can
talk to you about any
of the different services
that are available.
But in the booth, you'll see how
we've got our Citrix Workspace
family of subscriptions,
our Citrix Networking
family, and Citrix Analytics.
And we can give you
a much better feel
for how all those
things come together
and provide this thing called
the Secure Digital Workspace.
So one quick call to
action is if you've
got a digital transformation
project on the horizon,
keep us in mind.
The combination of
the two technologies
do a great job of taking
the world that you're
living in today, bridging
that into the cloud world,
and helping you get there at a
much higher speed and velocity,
and gain the value and the
benefits back out of it.
I gave you some
wrap up links here
to the different automation
frameworks that we've
got out there.
So there's no
reason, aside from I
don't happen to have
a project that I
could get into a GCP project.
All you need is a GCP project
and a trial subscription
to Citrix Cloud.
Grab that code and you
can have a bunch of fun.
So I pointed out our booth.
Come down and visit us.
We'll show you some pretty
cool use cases down there.
Partners, if there's any
partners in the room.
I will point out
that we are actually
looking for some very cloud
forward cloud first thinking
types of partners.
And the combination
of building a practice
around Google plus
Citrix is a great way
to differentiate
your business today.
[MUSIC PLAYING]